[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen Sonntagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen alles Wichtige vom
Sport hat Norbert König für Sie mit
einem schönen bunten Programm genommen
und wir blicken auf die Lage in
Frankreich
die fünfte Nacht in Folge in Frankreich
kommt es an neu zu Ausschreitungen
Schwerpunkt ist der Großraum Paris
wieder Angriffe auf Kiew die ukrainische
Luftabwehr wehrt die russischen Drohnen
ab
und Triumph in dramatischen stechen
Springreiter Markus Ehningen gewinnt
beim CHIO den Großen Preis von Aachen
[Musik]
in Frankreich hat die Großmutter des von
einem Polizisten getöteten 17-Jährigen
zu einem Ende der gewaltsamen Proteste
aufgerufen sie habe Vertrauen in die
Justiz dass der Beamte bestraft wurde
auch in der vergangenen Nacht gab es
Unruhen am Abend berät Präsident macron
über die Lage ein Bericht von einer
anderen
t Wut und Zerstörung die Randalierer
scheinen keine Grenzen zu kennen und
halten das Land in Atem die Gründe für
den Protest sind vielschichtig oft
steckt Frust dahinter in den Vorstädten
über Jahrzehnte gewachsen auch in porta
brannte es unweites bis groß von mokran
die Jugendlichen aus den Problemvierteln
schrecken vor nichts mehr zurück sie
sind völlig außer Kontrolle Hitzköpfe
diese Generation ist angstfrei
eine neue Stufe erreichen die Unruhen
mit dem Anschlag auf das Haus seines
Bürgermeisters in das ein Auto gerammt
und angezündet wird seine Frau und ein
Kind sind verletzt ermittelt wird wegen
Mordversuchs sie sagt solche Attacken
genau wie die Angriffe auf öffentliche
Gebäude Rathäuser Kommissariate werden
wir nicht akzeptieren und die Regierung
wird alle Mittel bereitstellen um die
Ordnung der Republik wieder herzustellen
der Grad der Gewalt sei von Nacht zur
Nacht unterschiedlich berichtet die
Polizei auch wenn die Zahl der
Festnahmen zurückgehe bedeutet das
mitnichten Entwarnung tausende Fahrzeuge
sind seit Beginn der Unruhen in Flammen
aufgegangen hier in porta wie in vielen
Vororten von Paris glaubt kaum einer an
ein baldiges Ende der Randale
mit der anfänglichen Wut über den Tod
des Jungen aus der Vorstadt haben die
nächtlichen Krawalle nicht mehr viel zu
tun sie eskalieren immer mehr und das
politische Klima trägt nicht gerade dazu
bei den Konflikt zu befrieden allen
voran die Politiker der extrem rechten
heizen eher noch weiter an und die
Strategie der Regierung mehr Härte mehr
Polizei kann die Ausschreitungen
vielleicht Lokal und kurzfristig
eindämmen sie löst aber nicht
langfristig das Problem der Spannungen
in der Gesellschaft der Präsident trifft
sich zur Stunde mit seinen Ministern ein
Lagebericht wird in Kürze erwartet fest
steht bereits auch heute Abend werden
wieder 45.000 Polizisten im Einsatz sein
beim geplanten heizungsgesetz geht seit
morgen in die entscheidende Phase er
soll es in den zuständigen
Bundestagsausschuss gehen die Opposition
wirft der Ampelkoalition vor das Gesetz
im horuckverfahren durchpeitschen zu
wollen und sieht die Rechte des
Parlaments missachtet dagegen hat sich
Kanzler Scholz heute im ARD
sommer-interview zur Wehr gesetzt
das ist ein sehr seriöses
Gesetzgebungsverfahren denn das ist ja
schon sehr lange im Gange sehr viele
Positionen sind öffentlich besprochen
und verhandelt worden sie haben das eben
beschrieben das ist ja sehr laut
vernehmbar gewesen deshalb wissen auch
alle worum es im Einzelnen geht ein
Kernpunkt des heizungsgesetzes ist ja
die kommunale wärmeplanung die steht
allerdings noch am Anfang zeigt eine
Umfrage des Deutschen Städtetags demnach
ist fast die Hälfte der befragten
Kommunen noch am koordinieren die andere
Hälfte arbeitet schon konkret an einer
wärmeplanung gerade mal vier Prozent
davon sind bereits an der Umsetzung ziel
ist es die heizinfrastruktur
klimaneutral umzubauen
mehr als 16 Monate dauert er schon der
russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine der us-auslandsgeheimdienst CIA
versucht in Russland mit Videos Agenten
anzuwerben in der Ukraine konnte ein
neuer Drohnenangriff auf die Hauptstadt
Kiew abgewehrt werden an der Front im
Süden und Osten gehen die Kämpfe weiter
wie bei bachmut Thomas konsior
der Ukraine ein russischer Panzer nah
bachmut plötzlich das
ukrainische Sprengfallen zerstören das
schwere Kampfgerät die russischen
Soldaten so zeigt das nicht überprüfbare
Video sie überleben müssen aber fliehen
in den Straßengraben
eine kleine Momentaufnahme im großen
Abnutzungskampf seit Wochen für Russland
eher Rückschläge Kiew verteidigt sich
auch heute früh ein Feuerschein zeugt
vom Abschuss einer russischen Drohne
alle Geschosse abgewehrt heißt es die
ausbleibenden Erfolge für Moskau sie
führen überall in Russland zu Frust und
damit zur Erosion von putinsystem glaubt
der US-Geheimdienst
die Unzufriedenheit mit dem Krieg wird
die russische Führung zunehmend
zersetzen und diese Unzufriedenheit gibt
uns eine einmalige Gelegenheit
konkret wendet sich die CIA mit Videos
über soziale Medien an Russlands
Bevölkerung Angst Unsicherheit ist dies
das Leben dass ihr euch vorgestellt habt
so die Frage und der Aufruf geht der CIA
versteckt Informationen
auch der Aufstand von wagner-chef
trikotin sei Anzeichen für Russlands
selbst Demontage geschlossen wurde nun
dessen büro-residenz in St Petersburg
weiter aufgebaut so zeigen neue
Satellitenbilder offenbar ein Wagner
Stützpunkt in Ossi powichi Belarus nur
200 km entfernt die ukrainische knapp
400 km die polnische Grenze beide will
man nun verstärkt schützen
Überwachung und Abwehr auch mit mehr
Drohnen auch an der Front in der Ukraine
denn der Aggressor Russland mag
angeschlagen sein geschlagen ist der
wohl noch lange nicht
in der US-Stadt Baltimore ist es in der
Nacht zu einer Schießerei mit vielen
Opfern gekommen eine 18-jährige und ein
20 Jahre alter Mann starben 28 weitere
Personen wurden Teil schwer verletzt in
einem Wohnviertel waren hunderte
Menschen offenbar zu einer jährlichen
Feier zusammengekommen warum es zu der
Schießerei kam ist noch unklar die
Mordkommission ermittelt in den USA gibt
es mehr Schusswaffen als Menschen in
keinem anderen Industrieland gibt es so
viele Tote durch Schüsse
die Schriftstellerin Valeria Gott Jeff
hat den diesjährigen Ingeborg
Bachmann-Preis gewonnen die gebürtige
Tübingerin setze sich beim
traditionellen Wettlesen durch mit ihrem
Text über einen Mann mit putzneurose
darin beschreibt Gott hierher von ihm
nicht als klinischen Fall sondern als
hingebungsvollen Menschen der
renommierte Literaturpreis ist mit
25.000 Euro dotiert und wird von der
Stadt Klagenfurt vergeben
und wir kommen zum Sport da konnten sich
die Reitsportfans nochmal über Deutsch
erfolgen Aachen Freunde dabei gab es für
eine erfolgsverwöhnte Dressurreiterin
eine Premiere
Olympiasiegerin Jessica von Bredo Werndl
hat nämlich mit ihrer Trakehnerstute der
Lehrer zum ersten Mal in ihrer Karriere
auch die Kühe in Aachen gewonnen beim
Springreiten gab es sogar einen dreifach
Erfolg
[Applaus]
aber unglaublich wer gesprungen ist über
drei Runden und ja ich kann es noch gar
nicht hätte ich glauben drei deutsche
Paare erreichen ein packendes stechen
Philipp Weishaupt
noch schneller
45,12 Sekunden es ist bereits ein
dritter Sieg beim Großen Preis in der
Aachen
triathlonstar Jan Frodeno feiert auf
seine Abschiedstour den ersten Sieg er
gewinnt nach 1,9 km Schwimmen 90 km
Radfahren und einem Halbmarathon das
Rennen in seiner Wahlheimat Andorra den
Ironman in Frankfurt am Main über die
doppelte Distanz gewinnt die
US-Amerikanerin Sarah true Laura Jansen
aus Heidelberg wird in ihrem ersten
klassischen Langstreckenrennen sehr gute
vierte
Max Verstappen fährt im alte Tempo
seinem dritten WM-Titel nacheinander in
der Formel 1 entgegen inklusive der
bisherigen Sprintwettbewerbe feiert der
Niederländer in Spielberg den achten
Sieg im elften Rennen
Spielberg leuchtet mal wieder in Oranien
schon zum fünften Mal gewinnt der
Niederländer Max Verstappen den Grand
Prix von Österreich es ist die
lieblingsrennstrecke des 25-Jährigen Red
Bull Piloten die Entscheidung in der 35
Runde Verstappen überholt Charlie clair
im Ferrari und bringt den Sieg souverän
ins Ziel vor lecler und Teamkollege
sacho Paris Nico Hülkenberg als Achter
gestartet fällt aus der deutsche muss
schon nach 13 Runden seinen Hass mit
hydraulikschaden abstellen
Deutschland hat wieder einen Weltmeister
im Profiboxen der 30 Jahre alte Vincenzo
quartieri holt sich in seiner
Heimatstadt Wuppertal den vakanten Titel
im Mittelgewicht des Weltverbandes IBF
durch einen einstimmigen Punkt sieht
nach 12 Runden gegen den Brasilianer
esviva v
und französischer Etappen Sieg am
zweiten Tag der Tour de France Victor
LaFee gewinnt nach 208 hügeligen
Kollegen im baskischen San Sebastian der
27-Jährige aus Lyon entwischt einen
Kilometer vorm Ziel der Spitzengruppe
und verteidigt seinen Vorsprung bis ins
Ziel in gelb bleibt der Brite Adam jetzt
das was danke Norbert und für alle die
privat gerne Musik machen ist es sicher
ein Traum einmal mit den deutschen
Sophie Sinfonieorchester und unter
Leitung eines berühmten Dirigenten
spielen
für einige hundert wurde dieser Traum
nun wahr durch den musikalischen
Flashmob in Bad Kissingen führte es da
dirigentner gano vier Musikstücke von
schauspielizee bis Giuseppe Verdi am
Ende der verdiente Lohn große Ablauf der
begeisterten Zuhörenden
und so wird das Wetter morgen gibt es
Sonne und Wolken im Nordwesten und an
den Alpen auch Schauer der Wind weht im
Norden frisch an den Küsten mit
Sturmböen die Temperaturen erreichen 18
bis 26 Grad
mariierter Slomka begrüßt sie um 21.45
zum heute-journal